Sam asgari addresses concerns over
Britney Spears's behavior on social
media and absence from public events the
public you know likes to judge in a
series of posts on his insta story Sam
explained that social media can be
traumatizing adding sometimes it's good
to take a break quote she has her voice
and is a free woman I'm just a normal
girl the posts come after his wife
deactivated her Instagram account on
Tuesday only to reactivate it on
Thursday afternoon a move she's done
multiple times before in fact back in
September 2021 Britt took down her
profile just days after she and Sam got
engaged My Philosophy is just take each
day at a time Sam also addressed why he
hasn't shared many pics of Brit lately
writing that he has respect for her
privacy and he protects it at all times
and the actor says when he does post
about Brittany he asks for permission
first she loves you know dancing working
out and really putting a cute content
she's been an artist forever so you know
models claim he recently got a lot of
heat for catching Brit off guard during
an Instagram live video I have nothing
to say
just to talk to them right now
or why the singer hasn't joined him on
the red carpet lately Sam explains that
while he has to attend events for his
job she's just not into public
appearances after years of being in the
spotlight quote it would be my honor if
she joins for her those things are not
fun they're hectic and full of stress
especially since she's been doing these
things since eight years old plus she
already slayed every single one she has
been to well thank you so much sweetie
Sam went on to ask fans to respect and
protect Brit's privacy imploring them
not to Hound her with questions and
theories about her online presence
adding quote sometimes being
overprotective can cause more stress and
damage what are you talking about should
I just turn the camera I don't need to
see anything I know some fans recently
speculated that the pop star doesn't
have control of her social media
accounts after Britney shared this
picture of her sister Jamie Lynn Spears
alongside a heartfelt caption calling
her brave and inspiring Brit and her
sister have been at odds for months
following the termination of Brit's
conservatorship and the subsequent
publication of Jamie Lynn's Memoir
things I should have said at the time
Brit called out her sister for the
timing of the book calling her scum my
sister knows I love and support her but
I can assure you that I've supported my
sister long before there was a hashtag
and I'll support her long after
Britney's lawyer sent Jamie Lynn's
attorney a cease and desist letter in an
effort to get Jamie Lynn to stop
mentioning Brit while promoting the
Memoir but not before she opened up to
E.T about her famous big sis I love and
support my sister and I respect her
healing process and however she has to
work through things and all I ask is
that I have that same space because it's
important everyone's process looks
different I just think that we should
all respect each other as you know as
for Brit while she may need to take a
break from social media from time to
time one thing's for sure she knows how
to keep her fans entertained
[Music]